wieder wirbel um astrazeneca nach neuen
thrombose fällen setzten mehrere
bundesländer den impfstoff für alle
unter 60 jährigen aus laschet unter
druck der cdu chef seine partei in die
zukunft führen sie und grenzt sich ab
von der kanzlerin nach der profit
erkrankung gerade jüngere menschen
klagen über langzeitwirkungen die sie
völlig aus der bahn werfen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport von schaewen bardorfer mir
es ist ein weiterer rückschlag für die
korona impfungen in deutschland nach
vereinzelten thrombose und todesfällen
stoppen erste bundesländer wieder das
verwenden von astrazeneca
diesmal sollen die unter 60 jährigen
nicht damit geimpft werden
vor einer halben stunde zog die ständige
impfkommission nach auch sie empfiehlt
astrazeneca nur noch für ältere im
moment beraten die gesundheitsminister
an seinem stern hat mir schon wieder
schlechte nachrichten schon wieder wegen
astrazeneca menschen unter 60 soll
dieser impfstoff nicht mehr gespritzt
werden entscheidet heute schon am frühen
nachmittag zum beispiel das land berlin
betroffen etwa kliniken wie die charité
oder auch große impfzentren dh in tegel
und tempelhof werden die termine von
unter 60 jährigen erst mal abgesagt
und dann wollen wir erstmal abwarten was
die empfehlung ist die empfehlung kommt
dann von der ständigen impfkommission
astrazeneca jetzt nur noch für über
60-jährige grund wohl auch diese zahlen
bis heute nachmittag wurden 31 fälle von
sogenannten sinus venenthrombosen nach
der impfung gemeldet in neun fällen mit
tödlichem ausgang betroffen insgesamt
zwei männer und 29 frauen im alter
zwischen 20 und 63
das risiko von weiteren todesfällen sei
zu hoch schreiben mehrere mediziner auf
der anderen seite wurden schon fast 2,7
millionen astrazeneca dosen in
deutschland verhilft fast immer ohne
schlimme folgen
ich finde nach wie vor dass wir es dann
nicht aussetzen sollten also die impfung
bei älteren ist ohne wenn und aber ohne
jede unterbrechung richtig aber die
begrenzung auf die gruppen die das
besondere risiko von kogit tragen aber
das geringste risiko
die nebenwirkung zu entwickeln das ist
richtig was ist richtig was ist falsch
bei astrazeneca in diesen minuten
beraten die gesundheitsminister von bund
und ländern krisensitzung schon wieder
in berlin gibt schon einen zwischenstand
aus den beratungen offensichtlich redet
die runde noch miteinander aber man muss
schon sagen das ergebnis scheint fast
schon klar zu sein denn so klar wie sich
die ständige impfkommission da geäußert
hat da wäre es verwunderlich wenn die
gesundheitsminister dem nicht folgen
würden es wäre auch nicht üblich
die ständige impfkommission hat da
offensichtlich den verdacht dass es
einen kausalen zusammenhang gibt
zwischen der impfung und diesen
thrombosen das hat jetzt noch mal ein
mitglied der kommission gegenüber dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland
bestätigt und wir warten jetzt minütlich
praktisch auf die entscheidung der
gesundheitsminister angela merkel wird
sich übrigens direkt im anschluss an
diese sitzung zusammen mit ihren sparen
und den ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
beraten denn das ganze wird hier
auswirkungen haben auf die impfstrategie
wahrscheinlich auch aufs tempo und da
will man sich heute abend noch darüber
verständigen wie es dann weitergehen
soll
ein weiterer interessanter abend
dankeschön nach berlin chuck unterlag
wie weiter mit astrazeneca diese frage
stellt auch ein zdf spezial direkt nach
positive nachrichten kommen dagegen von
beyond eckpfeiler der
impfstoffhersteller will seine
produktionskapazität bis ende des jahres
steigern um 25 prozent auf 2,5
milliarden dosen
möglich werde dies durch verbesserte
herstellungsprozesse die neue
produktionsstätte marburg und ein
erweitertes hersteller und
lieferantennetzwerk reisen in corona
zeiten ist komplex italien plant eine
quarantäne pflicht für alle die aus
einem eu land einreisen fünf tage auch
bei negativen corona test und in
deutschland gilt ab heute eine
testpflicht für alle die mit dem
flugzeug zu uns kommen egal woher und
das ist neu auch aus nicht-
risikogebieten und für die bei denen
corona nachgewiesen wird
ist das quarantäne im reiseland markus
wolsiffer kaum gelandet heißt dass
corona test bereit halten
wie hier am frankfurter flughafen von
heute an kontrolliert die bundespolizei
ob reisende einen negativen test
verweisen können so schreibt es die neue
verordnung vor wer zurück nach
deutschland will muss sich vor dem
abflug testen lassen
kostenpunkt etwa 30 bis 70 euro die
testerei mehr wieder urlaub 30 euro
musste hier zahlen für winters und ich
muss natürlich hingehen ist natürlich
auch urlaubs seite verloren geht dass
man nun auf einem nicht risikogebiet
unbedingt testen muss ist ein bisschen
schwierig nachzuvollziehen
erlaubt sind pcr oder schnelltests einer
zugelassenen stelle
der abstrich darf nicht älter als 48
stunden seien in der regel müssen die
reisenden selbst zahlen
auch für eine mögliche quarantäne vor
ort sollte der test positiv sein
in frankfurt gab es bisher keine
auffälligkeiten
dadurch dass der passagierverkehr am
frankfurter flughafen nicht mehr so groß
ist wie vor corona sind wir auch
personell dazu in der lage diese
maßnahmen jetzt umzusetzen
die fluggesellschaften unterstützen die
neuen auflagen sehen jedoch
handlungsbedarf
problematisch ist dass die
bundesregierung jetzt abweicht von der
bewährten differenzierung zwischen
risikogebieten und nicht risikogebieten
und wir sollten im mai wieder zu dieser
differenz ion zurückkehren
virologen begrüßen die neue verordnung
kritisieren jedoch dass kinder unter 6
jahren und die flugzeug cross von der
regelung ausgenommen sind und die korona
zahlen steigen weiter das robert koch
institut meldet neun 1549 neue corona
infektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 2064 mehr als eine woche zuvor
180 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incidents steigt auf
135,2 dabei sind die daten aus
baden-württemberg unvollständig cdu chef
armin laschet steht unter druck die
umfragewerte der partei sind im sinkflug
vorgestern kritisierte die kanzlerin
öffentlich seinen corona kurs zudem
sitzt im csu söder als konkurrent um die
kanzlerkandidatur im nacken
heute startete die cdu offiziell die
arbeit an ihrem wahlprogramm und armin
laschet versuchte boden gutzumachen
mathis feldhoff
eigentlich wollte der cdu-vorsitzende
heute für das eigene wahlprogramm werben
ein paar pflöcke einschlagen eingerahmt
in einen schwarz rot gelben kreis
digitalisierung klima europa doch statt
cdu pr show wird es erst einmal eine
pandemie entschuldigungs rede ich sage
ihnen heute wir werden das ändern wir
werden das besser machen
dafür stehe ich persönlich ein ein
versprechen mit vollem risiko lasse
zeigt er will kanzler werden die kritik
von angela merkel an seiner pandemie
strategie kommt zur unzeit
man kann ich zentral von oben herab bis
in die letzte institution regeln wer wie
wo wann geimpft werden kann welche
formulare ausgefüllt werden müssen wir
müssen denen die das vor ort machen mehr
zutrauen markus söder konkurrenten
unions internen kampf taktiert anders er
hatte den schulterschluss mit der
kanzlerin gesucht heute fragt er weiter
salz
die wunde ich finde es auch sehr seltsam
wenn der cdu vorsitzende mit der
cdu-kanzlerin ein halbes jahr vor der
wahl streit in der partei wird man
ungeduldig laschet oder söder
das müsse jetzt geklärt werden wir
müssen zeigen dass wir corona management
können und dann kann schnellstmöglich
der kanzlerkandidat bestimmt werden
gepaart mit einem programm das sich
gewaschen hat die umfragen im sturzflug
die spitze im streit die union sucht
nach der wende eine wichtige
entscheidung meldet die metall und
elektroindustrie es gibt einen
tarifabschluss möglicherweise mit
signalwirkung für andere branchen in der
unsicheren corona zeit einigten sich
gewerkschaft und arbeitgeber nicht auf
feste lohnaufschläge sondern sie
vereinbarten einmalzahlungen oberstes
ziel dabei jobs sichern
thomas münten 4 prozent mehr pro monat
hat die ig metall für die aktuelle
tarifrunde in der metallindustrie
gefordert nach einer langen
verhandlungsnacht ergibt sich ein völlig
anderes bild
so erhalten alle beschäftigten zum 30
juni dieses jahres eine einmalige corona
pauschale von 500 euro netto
der zweite teil des tarifabschlusses ist
kompliziert zwar wird ab juli 2021 das
gehalt um 2,3 prozent monatlich erhöht
ausgezahlt wird diese erhöhung als
einmalbetrag erst im februar 2022 aber
wenn ein unternehmen in finanzielle
schwierigkeiten gerät kann das geld bei
arbeitszeitkürzungen zum lohnausgleich
verwendet werden
ein jahr später soll sich das
wiederholen dort wo wir über
arbeitszeitabsenkung beschäftigung
sichern können damit auch einen festen
kündigungsschutz haben
da kann dieses geld genommen werden um
das monatseinkommen zu verstetigen
die arbeitgeber sind mit dem kompromiss
zufrieden er gebe ihnen den notwendigen
handlungsspielraum wenn wir das nicht
nötig haben peter ausgezahlt dann werden
die beträge ausgezahlt
viele arbeiter erfuhren heute mittag
erst vom neuen tarifvertrag die resonanz
ist geteilt
ist es nicht so dass was wir eigentlich
wollten aber besser als gar nichts neues
wenn die sich jetzt weiterhin haare
haben und sich nicht einigen können
leute die im endeffekt nichts dafür tun
nur die einfach nur geld reinstecken
kriegen kriegen ihre dividenden kriegen
sie dann mehr die wir den ausgeschüttet
und die leute die rudern müssen gehen im
endeffekt leer aus der tarifabschluss
gilt als modell für die branche in der
gesamten bundesrepublik
die preise in deutschland steigen wie
seit einem jahr nicht mehr plus 1,7
prozent die aktuelle teuerungsrate
zuletzt lag die inflation bei 1,3
besonders die energiepreise haben
überdurchschnittlich angezogen
schwerer verdacht gegen 17 beamte einer
spezialeinheit des lka in dresden sie
sollen 7000 schuss munition entwendet
haben
damit sei offenbar ein illegales
schießtraining auf einer zwielichtigen
privaten anlage bezahlt worden
vier polizisten wurden suspendiert 13
strafversetzt es läuft ein
ermittlungsverfahren wegen diebstahls
bestechlichkeit und möglicher verstöße
gegen das waffengesetz ganz anderes
thema jetzt zehn jahre bürgerkrieg haben
syrien zu einem großen teil zerstört
eine internationale geberkonferenz
versucht nun dringend benötigte
hilfsgelder zu organisieren
in einer stunde wollen die teilnehmer
bekannt geben wie viel zusammengekommen
ist deutschland hat bereits rund 17
milliarden euro zugesagt die hilfe soll
auch in die nachbarländer fließen in die
millionen syrer geflüchtet sind einige
der menschen die vor dem bürgerkrieg in
syrien flüchten stranden auch in
griechenland speziell auf den
ägäisinseln dort leben fast 16.000
migranten und asylsuchende nach dem
brand im lager moria auf lesbos im
september mussten tausende umziehen nach
charakter
menschenrechtsorganisationen kritisieren
die zustände dort scharf aus dem sonst
abgeschirmten lager berichtet unsere
korrespondentin annette hilsenbeck
journalisten dürfen ins lager car at t
das erste mal seit monaten flankiert von
polizei man zeigt eine trockengelegte
fläche auf dazu vor zelte gestanden
haben im herbst und winter warnt immer
wieder handybilder kursiert die das camp
nach regen überschwemmt zeigten in
diesem teil des camps sind
verbesserungsarbeiten zu sehen die zelte
sind abgeräumt worden und kanäle gezogen
doch im hinteren teil des camps soll
nach wie vor das wasser stehen
in den zelten sobald es anfängt zu
regnen
das erzählen flüchtlinge die in dem teil
wohnen den wir nicht sehen dürfen
es ist schlimm wir können nachts wegen
der kälte nicht schlafen
das essen ist schlimm zu wenig toiletten
ein ganz neues lager- und der eu
verwaltung statt dem übergangs champ car
at t entertain sitz die eu heute darauf
in griechenland auf eine bessere
verteilung der flüchtlinge
wir haben jetzt insgesamt 276 millionen
euro für fünf neue lage auf den inseln
bitte licht ich bin sehr daran
interessiert dass neue in migrations und
asylpolitik ihren und dabei zu einer
kompromisslösung zu kommen die eine
faire verteilung der lasten innerhalb
der eu einführt die flüchtlinge sind zum
teil seit monaten auf lesbos sie wollen
kein neues camp sie wollen weg weiter
nach europa
zurück zum thema corona und der frage
woher genau kommt das virus mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit von tieren
das erklärte heute die
weltgesundheitsorganisation neben
fledermäusen könnten auch schuppentiere
die quelle sein
gesucht wird noch dazwischen wird
forscher der whu waren anfang des jahres
in china
es sei nicht klar ob der markt in haan
tatsächlich der ausgangspunkt der
pandemie war dass das virus aus einem
labor kommt sei extrem unwahrscheinlich
die whu will aber weiter zum ursprung
des virus forschen
eine infektion mit dem corona virus kann
auch jüngere leute völlig aus der bahn
werfen mit dramatischen langzeitfolgen
nach schätzungen bekommen ein bis zwei
prozent der kogit patienten das
chronische erschöpfungssyndrom
bislang ist es nicht heilbar was das
bedeutet zeigt zum teil vor seiner cupid
19 infektion war florian sportlich und
voller energie reiste durch die welt
jetzt hat sich sein leben um 180 grad
gedreht er fährt nicht mal mehr selbst
auto das risiko möchte ich einfach
selber nicht eingehen zumal ich weiß
dass mein kopf nicht hundertprozentig
funktioniert stand heute hat kobelt mir
meine freiheit um eine unabhängigkeit
genommen über ein jahr ist die kogit
infektion jetzt her
der 28 jährige leidet an chronischen
fatigue syndrom ist immer noch
krankgeschrieben
ich habe es früher gemerkt dass einfach
die energie und die belastbarkeit nicht
mehr besteht dass der körper einfach
komplett ausgebaut ist und keine energie
art und die symptome die ich
grundsätzlich habe wie straßen oder
dieser stünde einmal war noch mal
verstärkt ist laut einer studie der
charité sind viele jüngere menschen an
chronischen fertig syndrom erkrankt man
könne zwar helfen sie aber nicht heilen
um das aber möglich und zu können
brauchen wir zugelassene medikamente und
dafür brauchen wir zunächst klinische
studien und daran
das modell kann auch weil einfach die
pharmazeutische industrie da bislang
sehr konservativ war und gesagt hat so
lange er uns nicht genau sagt was der
mechanismus der erkrankung ist es das so
riskant medikamente zu entwickeln
florian verbringt gerade 80 prozent des
tages rund er hofft noch immer dass ich
seine beschwerden bessern jung und
schwer krank durch corona mehr zum thema
um 9 im zdf im frontal21 jetzt zur
fußball nationalmannschaft noch mit ihm
zu machen
das letzte wm qualifikationsspiel und da
heißt die devise von bundestrainer
joachim löw aller guten dinge sind drei
also drittes quali spiel dritter sieg
gegen nord mazedonien wird es in der
dfb-elf nur kleine veränderungen geben
marc andré ter stegen wird das tor hüten
für die nummer eins des fc barcelona
steht das erste länderspiel seit
november 2009 10 bevor
damals noch mit zuschauern ilkay
gündogan übernimmt die kapitänsbinde von
manuel neuer
der formstarke mittelfeldspieler von
manchester city war beim 13 0 gegen
island unter den torschützen form meines
lebens würde ich nichts mit ja
beantworten
aber für mich kann es ja wohl das
trainerteam wird voraussichtlich wenig
wechseln die mannschaft so sich weiter
einspielen
es ist wieder kompakter es ist
mannschaftlich geschlossener und davon
profitiere alle mannschaftsteile für
joachim löw ist die partie gegen nord
mazedonien das letzte
qualifikationsspiel als bundestrainer
bayern münchen muss für vier wochen auf
weltfußballer robert lewandowski
verzichten der 32 jährige stürmer hatte
sich im wm qualifikationsspiel der
polnischen nationalmannschaft gegen
andorra am sonntagabend eine
bänderdehnung im rechten knie zugezogen
er ist ein torgarant sowohl für den fc
bayern als auch für sein polnisches
nationalteam für das er vor zwei tagen
noch in der wm-qualifikation gegen
andorra zwei tore erzielte als er nach
gut einer stunde ausgewechselt wurde
wusste noch niemand um die schwere der
verletzung die den 32 jährigen zu einer
rund vierwöchigen auszeit zwingt auch im
letzten bundesliga spiel der bayern
gegen den vfb stuttgart schraubte
lewandowski seine torquote mit drei
weiteren auf insgesamt 35 treffer nun
schon in sichtweite der 40 rekord von
gerd müller
der zeitpunkt der verletzung des polen
kommt für die bayern denkbar schlecht da
sie jetzt sowohl am samstag im
spitzenspiel bei rb leipzig als auch in
der champions league gegen paris st
germain auf den weltfußballer verzichten
müssen
das was von sport der frühling weckt die
lebens und die kreative geister zu sehen
ist das derzeit in oybin in sachsen 1700
ostereier an einem baum das ist
rekordverdächtig
vor einem vierteljahrhundert hat
besitzerin erna die sammelleidenschaft
gepackt seitdem leuchtet mir osterbaum
jedes frühjahr aufs neue
der märz endet morgen mit temperaturen
zwischen 21 und 26 grad das ist
ungewöhnlich warm bleibt aber auch nicht
lang so wann es wieder kälter wird sagt
ihnen gleich katja um viertel vor zehn
das heute journal mit christian sievers
wir danken herzlich für ihr interesse
machen sie dort machen sie sich noch
einen schönen abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren strahlender
sonnenschein und temperaturen von 25
grad da könnten wir fast vergessen dass
wir noch märz haben und auch wenn es
tagsüber schon temperaturen über 20 grad
geht nachts wird es natürlich kalt am
rhein sinken die temperaturen in dieser
nacht auch acht oder neun grad am
alpenrand geht es in den leichten frost
von minus 1 grad dazu ist der himmel
meist sternenklar und selten bildet sich
hier im nordosten mal etwas nebel und
auch morgen gibt es wieder viel
sonnenschein und höchstens ein paar
kleine harmlose schleierwolken bei
westwind steigen die temperaturen morgen
in der uckermark bis 22 grad im breisgau
werden dass 26 grad und nur an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee ist es bei
16 bis 19 grad etwas kühler jedenfalls
wenn der wind übers wasser weht an
gründonnerstag wird es ein bisschen
kühler von norden und dann kann es hier
im osten auch mal ein bisschen regnen im
süden merken sie davon noch nichts da
wird's noch mal richtig warm und bis zu
26 grad an karfreitag setzt sich die
etwas kühlere luft weiter richtung süden
fort dann liegen die temperaturen bei
acht bis 20 grad am karsamstag ist es
für uns alle dann trocken schönen abend
noch